my guest tonight is an emmy
award-winning comedian and
actor who co-created and starred in the
british television series the office
his most recent series afterlife can be
streamed on netflix
uh please welcome our good friend mr
ricky gervais ricky how are you
good yeah fine you are in
uh you are in england and i understand
you guys
just went into lockdown again is that
right yeah
our second wave um we just come out
actually but uh
it it went went crazy again um and so
yeah we're on our second lockdown just
for one
uh one month to sort things out so right
yeah
it's like this year has been no
different to me i don't know whether in
lockdown or not really
it doesn't make a lot of difference to
me i've i never liked people coming to
the house
i've always got enough booze for a
nuclear winter so
i'm always on the couch in pajamas by
six o'clock watching netflix so the
evenings literally haven't changed
so it suits me but this is good i like
this as well
i i the fact that i don't have to see
you in person or smell you
is good you know what i mean it makes a
i think i understand
yeah i'm happier i'm certainly happier
in this interview than our previous
yes yes ricky you've always complained
you've always complained
and to be fair to you for many years
when you would come on the show you'd
say i'd love to do this but over
zoom i'd love to be six thousand miles
away from you
yeah what is great which makes me think
how terrible
we had a pandemic before in the 17th
century
the great plague and there was no zoom
and that was awful yeah that was
dreadful
right you know people back said
many history many people wrote back in
their journals back then if only there
was a way we could speak to each other
with kind of crappy resolution and a lag
time
wouldn't our lives be better so
ricky this has to be tough for you
because i've known you for a while and
let me point out also we're on different
time schedules so you're not drinking
alcohol
early in the morning um i want to make
that very clear to people
i mean i'm hardly drinking alcohol it's
beer which is a soft drink
in england
that's what you think when you're
i forgot that in england and ireland uh
when you go to a restaurant you buy a
child a beer
instead of like uh yeah
yeah even if it's not your child you
just say drink
drinks for all the kids you're a rich
american
you go to dublin i've done that i've
done that many times
children of ireland i want
guinness for all the kids while i'm here
um
listen i've known you for a while you're
a bit of a hypochondriac you worry
constantly about your health
and your well-being so
anything how are you handling a plague
we have a modern-day plague
how's that going well for the first
few days of the lockdown every other day
i thought i'd caught it i said to jane
i've definitely i've got a temperature
she'd go no you haven't she even bought
a thermometer
online so she could go no you haven't
right and then
i i always think the worst and i google
it as well
so if i find a lump i think well that's
that's terminal it could be a pimple
or anything at the moment though um
to be fair though i'm sometimes right
like i had root canal work
and uh um i went to the dentist and
they're all in their
gear and everything and i had and now
i've got a gum boil
so all that i've got a gum a gum boil a
gum boil
what is it i've got a i've got a um
a bad [ __ ] a gum boil i've got bad back
bad knees and i do complain right and i
think oh i'm gonna die
but one day i will be right in fact
as time goes on i've got more and more
chance
of being right haven't i it's not my
name used to do this
for the last 20 years of my nan's life
she'd go oh i won't see
christmas this year and the last year
she was right
so i mean
and when i had the um i had the
infection it was an infected tooth
um they gave me some a prescription to
get uh
some antibiotics and i went to get the
antibiotics
and the pharmacist said oh um
don't drink alcohol with these because
they make you violently sick
so i came home and told jane and she
went that'd be good
um not out drinking for a few days and i
went
i'm going to drip i'm not going to drink
the i'm not going to take the
antibiotics
right and she went you've got to take
the antibiotics so i compromised
and i drank and took the antibiotics
and i woke up that night in a sweat
feeling sick
going i've got coronavirus she said
remember you drank and took the
antibiotics i went oh yeah
yeah i i remember
i did just what they told me not to do
i want to ask you about a boil nobody's
had a boil
in in like 400 years no one gets a boil
anymore that's uh
that's something that there's some
middle age i know 1400's disease
it's really weird um i've got a gum boy
i've got something wrong on the feet
like
chill planes or something or i don't
know um
what am i going to get next a goiter i
mean
suffering from those things i i went to
the doctor and then i had an all over
medical last year
and at one point he said you're pre gout
pre
gout scout what does that mean um
it's urea in the bloodstream so i think
from
booze and uh yeah i had all over medical
i feel like those things right and i
tell the truth
except units of alcohol and i always
halve those
yeah when the doctor gets to those he
goes oh that's a lot i think
i've won i go is it you know
[Laughter]
so your doctor thinks it's a lot even
when you cut the number
of glasses you have a day in half your
doctor says it's too much yeah but
what are the i mean they just make these
figures up don't they it's fine also
people say to me if you if you gave up
booze you'd live ten years longer i
think yeah but they'll be the last ten
years
they're the rubbish ten i don't want
those ten years if i can have like
20 to 30 again that'd be great but
you've got to have
80 to 90 and um that's that's no fun
i've seen 90 year olds sitting in an
armchair right
and they suddenly go oh what i've broken
every bone in my body
you just get brittle and i just think
it's no much
just just have fun and then die kids
and i don't i don't know do you mind if
we put that together for a public
service announcement that we win
here in america just have fun and then
die kid says ricky
my body like an old car i don't need a
new one
i can't have a new one right it's going
to wear out i'm just going to have as
much fun and just break down and they
just have to tow it away
and crush me and i you know and you know
we're all going to die
so being healthy is just dying more
slowly
so i i'm not going to stop anything you
know
i don't i i don't i this is the most
dangerous thing i do
i'm sitting down at home right and then
and it turns out someone can just cough
on you and kill you
with that no one you know i'm beginning
to think i
i wish i hadn't eaten all those bats for
christmas
what's that you ate them raw that's the
problem you need to thoroughly cook a
bat before you eat it ricky
rose were into your raw bats which was
uh
question i i told you this i was in
england and i got a chance to talk to
you and i was telling you how much i
like your show afterlife i really do
uh like the series and we've got a new
season now and we talked about the time
the show is i really love it it's also
it's dark
and it's clear that you are thinking a
lot about your own mortality all the
time and it's
it influences your work do you think
about it do you think about
how you want to go i think that um i
think i'm drawn to it and i think
comedians are obsessed with it
because it's the last taboo and it makes
people feel uncomfortable and i like
taking people to the dark place
and you know it's like taking them
through a scary forest and out the other
side i think that
no harm can come from discussing taboo
subjects and i think
we find that funny we find being scared
funny and um and and death obviously is
the ultimate but
i don't i don't think i think more of it
more when i die i think um
i'm resigned to it you know we're all
gonna die there's nothing i can do about
it
so the best thing is to enjoy life as
much as you can and um
i don't really i don't really care about
i don't care about being dead
because i won't know about it that is
that is the best thing about being dead
it's right you're not like being stupid
it's only painful for others
yeah um but i suppose i worry about how
i die i don't want to die
you know alone or in agony or i don't
want to die an embarrassing death
you know what i mean i think about that
a lot i don't want to be embarrassed or
humiliated in any way
i you know i i don't want that i don't
want that i want it to be a very
dignified death
exactly like um there was a there was a
uh years ago there was a british mp
that was found hung
in his wardrobe right wearing ladies
tights
with an orange laced with ammo nitrate
i mean it was masturbating let's be
honest
there's no doubt about that so i mean i
would you know we wouldn't want to be
fat
if i am found i'm not into that stuff so
if i am found like that
right one of my friends has stitched me
up they've dressed me up after my death
and called the papers i just want to say
that now right
could you have you got a ward i bet you
haven't got a wardrobe big enough for
you to hang yourself while masturbating
have you
no i don't have a very small closet i've
actually tested it to see could i hang
myself in here
while masturbating and i've i've i had
carpenters come in
and they were saying no no no no you
don't have enough room for that
you know because masturbating you need
elbow room and i would love to see you
shopping that would be great
could i speak to the manager what is it
what's your what's your biggest what's
your roomiest wardrobe
yeah and i'll be honest with the guy
i'll say look
i need to hang myself while masturbating
and there's no
here for that plus you still need room
for the clothes
and so yeah we're talking about here
yeah
and you don't need to be too suspicious
you don't want people to walk into your
bedroom and go
is that a death wanking wardrobe
and then when you go inside there's like
you know thing like steps
and like a really good bar a really good
weight
[Laughter]
uh now are you one you want to be do you
want to be buried cremated have you
thought about that
do you want what do you want to happen
with your body once you're gone
um don't care i thought it would be good
to be um
just fed to the lions at london zoo
that would be useful isn't it because we
never give anything back we take
everything from this world we just
we animals anything that moves we eat we
destroy we
deforestation club we don't give
anything back everything we do is for us
we're not even food for other things so
i just thought at least then
i'd be giving so i also i like the look
on the tourist faces when they
they just throw this like dead fat
naked uh that's 73 year old
maybe if i'm lucky to the lions and as
it lands some people go
is that the blue from the office
what's steve corral no not
the original office he's much farther
he's much fatter than steve west steve
caroll's still alive
and look really handsome and so the
lions the whole time that the tourists
are watching are just ripping you apart
but the people are going oh they've
never seen a person be eating for
also i like the idea that the lion they
all start with the soft bits
but if two lions went for my testicles
right they'd be in for a shot because
they're really gristly
and long so you'd have two lines like
about three feet apart
it'd be like lady in the [ __ ] they're
eating my testicles getting close
together
then they meet in the middle and kiss
yeah and they fall in love
and all the tourists go ah
[Laughter]
you know one thing you're doing that uh
is great is
you're staying sane by doing a uh uh
sort of a live stream
on twitter and what's really nice is
that
your fans you got a lot of fans they get
to talk to and they get to ask you
absurd questions and then you ask is the
best that is the best thing about it
because um
podcasts are great and shows are great
but i think that
there the audience is watching other
people talking to each other whereas
this i'm actually talking to them and
i'm answering their questions and some
of the questions are really good in fact
i want to do it live and use some of
their
questions because they're they range
from really
interesting philosophical questions to
just ridiculous
questions but it's it's it's really good
fun and you're right it keeps me sane
and it's free and it's like a it's like
a big
sort of online club so i'm really
enjoying that yeah
what kind of questions have you gotten
that you've really liked where
our one question was um they know i love
sort of science and nature and they said
what is the most amazing fact
about nature and that's really because
it makes you think because it's
so amazing my answer was
um humans are more closely related to
salmon than salmon are to sharks
so it's just the vastness that
the length of time the number of
generations
in evolution and uh
and then someone asked me would i rather
have
thumbs for nipples or nipples for thumbs
so
what's your answer the difference i said
i'd rather have thumbs for nipples
because then i could hitchhike while
reading a book
[Laughter]
i think i want the nipples uh on the
thumbs i want i want
yeah because then i can constantly i can
wear mittens and constantly be arousing
myself and no one knows
just wearing mittens and i'm just
constantly in a state of full arousal
but my hands are cold if they were
functioning if they were lactating
nipples
you'd you'd be able to have a little bit
of sustenance wouldn't you yes you'd
have a
black coffee and then yeah yeah
i mean you'd be you'd be a a grown
very famous six foot six man sucking his
thumb
right in public you go no no no it's
nipples
don't get me wrong that's the nipple and
they go oh
oh okay trust me they all know that i
was the guy who kept trying to hang
himself while masturbating so
in the hierarchy of embarrassing things
i'm doing
this there was
there's a nice one um uh if a time
traveler comes to your door
from 25 years in the future and you're
allowed to ask him
one question which i thought was really
that was really good as well
what would you ask him i would say uh
um how was i murdered you know i really
want to know
cause i know someone's gonna kill me
it's inevitable
i would say and i might even be more
specific and say how did ricky gervais
murder me
yeah exactly yeah you'd be like oh well
what ricky did was really clever
it was the old collapsing wardrobe trick
[Laughter]
um as you know obviously that's what
social media is for
and i like it the cats and dogs they
they ask
questions from their perspective there's
one there's one uh
dog that called bella who's a whippet
that asked me questions
and one of her questions was um i see
you've won a lot of awards
but have you ever found a really good
stick and taking it all the way home
[Laughter]
who's to say what's the bigger
accomplishment who's to say
yeah exactly yeah um
a question about your lovely girlfriend
jane who i've met many times
lovely person you guys have been
together for i think 38 years now is
that right
39 years do you ever think of popping
the question or have you decided
who needs that you know where our
relationship's fine without getting
married
yeah we don't want our families to meet
[Laughter]
really okay that's the best reason yet
i've ever heard for not getting
i should say that lockdown's been a lot
harder for jane
than me because she's a novelist so
she usually gets the house to herself
you know
to work but because i'm home right i
keep hearing i go
shush i'll play with you in a minute let
me just finish this sentence
so it must be like having a toddler home
yes i have the same situation because my
wife uh
is a is a playwright and she'll be
working on
serious theater work in the basement and
i'm just wandering around at starved for
attention
i have no audience and i'm trying to do
schtick and bits for her and she's she's
giving me ritalin now
she's giving this the same medication
they give to hyperactive children
she's putting it hey now jane gets up at
5 00 am
so she gets two or three hours to write
before i get up
so she has to play with me
well uh you are a uh this has made my
day
talking to you has really made my day
and it's been fun
yeah i i love i always love talking to
you but
right now especially right now when they
when i found out i get to talk to ricky
gervais today i thought
okay that's a good day in quarantine
i'll take it so
uh i want you to be well i want you to
stay well
um i know you miss me terribly i do no i
do miss you
i loved our chat it was lovely seeing
you when you came over
and uh i loved doing the show whenever i
where i can
and i still remember um when i had to do
one of those emmy things and you
graciously uh hosted it for me and it
was the best one i've ever done
it was it was so much fun seeing you out
of your natural environment off the
table
it's really good yeah you also have
better
put downs for me than anyone i've ever
met and i'm putting you
i i have all the best
uh the sharpest comedians have good
conan o'brien put downs
you always come in with some of the best
and i compliment you for that
they're very very good yes you always
let your natural disdain come through
hey let me get the word out seasons one
and two of afterlife
are available to stream on netflix and
it's really is a terrific show i love it
it's sweet and it's it's sweet and it's
funny and
uh it actually does feel like a very
good show for right now
it is a lot of people have said it's
helped them through not only lockdown
but their own grief and stuff because it
ultimately it's uplifting and uh
positive and it's very dark and it's
very funny even though it's about
that subject it's funny because i play a
guy who says
what he wants because i don't care about
life anymore so i should
i should say is a comedy um it is a
comedy no it's it's very
trust me it's i think people would know
just you being involved it would be a
comedy but it's very funny
and uh uh as you always say to me cheers
um be well and uh cut your alcohol
consumption down to
i'm gonna say 15 glasses a day
how big are the glasses i've got a very
very large
64 ounce
you do the conversion for me i don't
have the patience i don't you know
uh hey ricky thank you very much yes my
pleasure
you